he's Reggie Miller he's calling warriors
Rockets tomorrow night at 8:00 Eastern
on TNT aloysius how are you happy Happy
New Year Theodore to you and yours as
well as my dad Nets Happy New Year to
say when I called in earlier I was
talking to Fritzi and he was telling me
about his fabulous trip to Israel with
the family which was great so I hope
everyone had a safe and happy new year
in 2018 is going to be even better for
all of us you start out the New Year's
where we thought we were getting a great
matchup warriors rockets and no James
Harden are you getting Chris Paul at
least I hope Turner you know trying to
cop on the foot I'm a little sick I
admit this game no look I think Chris
Paul will play but if you're Mike
D'Antoni you've got to be very cautious
of the workload now that Harden is going
to be out two to three weeks with the
hamstring injury we know the record when
they play together I believe they're 11
or 12 and one when they're on the floor
together but you don't want to attacks
Chris Paul too much because you know at
the Asia he's doing now you don't want
him to have some lingering issues as the
season continues I was wondering about
this with certain players in certain
sports and how they they change the
sport I verse and I think changed the
NBA in in a cultural way Deion Sanders
changed how defensive players defensive
backs acted and pranced tanned taunted
and had fun with the game and then I
look at Steph Curry his impact on the
NBA
and his impact on basketball the ability
to take that quick shot we're seeing
Trey young the Oklahoma player who's
leading the nation in scoring do you do
you see this as something that will look
back on Steph Curry's impact because I
don't remember somebody else who had a
shot this quick like Steph Curry you
have to play the mmm excuse me the
Golden State Warriors totally different
way
and curries on the floor I look at the
games that he missed this year with the
ankle injury
and look Kevin Durant was fantastic has
been having an MVP fantastic season but
the Warriors are so much different with
Steph Curry because of the ability you
just mentioned of having that quick
trigger but in pick-and-roll situations
he puts the teams in such a disadvantage
do you switch you can't go under because
they'll knock down to three do you hard
hedge well he's a great passer and if
you just get caught on the screen you're
pretty much dead so it's the way he
plays we have not seen before the quick
trigger the passing but can you touch
that shot can you learn that that shot
that's god-given that's that's that's
Poppa Dale that's Papa Dale curry and
give him a lot of credit for being in
the lab and working on his craft but a
lot of that is god-given and obviously
he had to hone and bring that but that's
God dad hand-eye coordination that's
something that's given from the man
above yeah it just feels like there are
certain players who change how we look
at the position or how they play the
position and and I just see a lot of
these kids who are trying to imitate
that now they're not going to shoot the
way he does but it feels like you know
get that shot off as quick as possible
because even somebody you know his size
is getting a shot over anybody
and that gives players like Trey young
you mentioned from Oklahoma and other
players who are in that six foot two six
two six three range as point guard it
gives them hope and belief well if I
have a quick enough trigger and I can
knock down threes or consistent basis
well I can play eight to twelve years in
the NBA and have a pretty successful
career we also had Jordan with the
ability to jump but you know not
everybody has that same ability so I
sort of see it the same way with with
Jordan's ability of dunking and then
Steph's ability with that quick trigger
but that didn't stop all the imitators
with these two guys well no one was ever
going to jump like MJ but
oh great Vince could write yes but Vince
didn't have the low post strength that
MJ had so people forget how great a vet
fade away to me people talk about the
jumping and the dunking which was great
that was the exclamation point but
Jordan was a load in the post it was
like he was Wilt Chamberlain at 65 66
you could not move him off the post and
in that fadeaway there was no way
talking about the leaping ability there
was no way you're gonna be able to block
that Vince is a hall-of-famer ring men's
guard house to Lily
absolutely pretty amazing though it at
40 he's still at age 40 he probably
jumps better than a lot of guys did at
25 well because of science I think guys
are taking care of their bodies a little
bit more and everyone's hiring chefs and
people have physical therapists you're
able to play longer I think coaches are
doing a good job of monitoring minutes
you know we talked about Vince look at
what LeBron James is doing in his 15th
season I know he's only 33 got but to
get remember he came in out of high
school think about in your 15th year
arguably having your best year guys are
taking care of their bodies during the
offseason they're eating more healthy
and I think the ability to play longer
and be productive at that age I mean
Vince that's he's giving hope to a lot
of guys that once they hit you know
usually when you hit 34 or 35 people
start talking about retirement but if
you take care of your body and you're in
the right system you could very well
play into your late 30s Reggie has
warriors Rockets tomorrow night at 8:00
Eastern on TNT Isiah Thomas is not going
to play against Boston tonight
are you surprised I'm not surprised I
would if I was i T which is great you
know the game last night in Portland I
would want to be healthy going against
the Celtics in Kyrie you know this is
his second would have been his second
game back yeah and to be
not a hundred percent in the Boston
Garden he wants to be a hundred percent
going at those guys so I could respect
the decision to sit I know the probably
won't sit well with a lot of fans
because they want to see that matchup
but if you're the Cavaliers you're just
happy to have them back on the floor the
difference makes though with that lineup
now as we move forward with what you saw
let's say he's healthy but the
difference he makes with Boston is gonna
be what you and I talked about this that
we were really weren't going to be able
to judge the Cavaliers until I T came
back
number one it adds depth and it's going
to allow LeBron James to rest now either
on the bench or in the fourth quarter
because now you can give Isaiah the ball
and he can get you anywhere from 8 to 12
consecutive points the only liability
will be at the other end offensively
because if you're certain teams you're
gonna put him and a plethora of picking
the rolls to test that hip and if you're
a bigger guard you're gonna try to take
him into the post to try to exploit him
but this is a plus for coach Lew and the
Cavs
because once everyone gets healthy
DeRose Shumpert now Isaiah Thomas this
is a very to me they were already the
team to beat because of LeBron James
play but now that they're gonna get a
healthy Isiah Thomas back knock on wood
that he returns to some kind of form of
that Boston Celtics where he averaged
almost 30 points
they're the team to beat in the east and
we'll see what happens when they go
against whomever out of coming out of
the West why is it when you have a guy
who scores a lot but he's not a great
defender we always point that out like I
always say you have to guard that guy
well Steve Nash can't guard anybody well
who's guarding Steve Nash or right but
you know Isiah Thomas you know scores 29
a game but he can't Garden anybody well
I'm gonna guess he's gonna win his match
up every single time if we're gonna
compare numbers on are you stopping him
or is he stopping you Dan it only really
gets highlighted come playoff yeah
you're right during the regular season
we won't even mention it but when you
get locked into a seven-game series
especially the further you advance
because teams start to take things away
and as great as Isaiah is
he has challenged at times defensively
and that's not fair to handed because of
his size so it starts to get exploited
the deeper you go on playoffs and you
get to Eastern Conference Finals or an
NBA Finals you start to pick things out
a little bit kevin durant has made a
conscious effort to be a better defender
this year and it almost feels like he
was being labeled as just a
one-dimensional guy like he's a great
scorer do you think it's a conscious
effort on his part to say hey i can be
the all-around player LeBron James is I
think it's the dream on green effect
having dream on in is yeah I think
having draymond Green in his ear and
seeing the work ethic that dream on
brings every day to the defensive end
look Kevin Durant has always had all the
skills to be a great defensive player
but the only thing that's really been
highlighted up until this year really
was his offense because he's a brilliant
score but to me this is the reason why
him and LeBron along with James Harden
but now that he's out with the injury
are probably highlighting the MVP race
what he's doing defensively especially
the blocks because he's 72 and he has a
wingspan so it's a load for most
defenders and it's a plus if you're
Steve Kerr to have draymond Green the
rookie Jordan Bell who's another
draymond Green effect and Kate Cady I
mean that's three great defensive
players and you throw in klay Thompson
who is a fantastic two way player that's
why to me it's going to be very
difficult for anyone to beat to go to
stay warriors when healthy not only are
they a juggernaut offensively but
defensively they can get after you are
you own the LA Rams bandwagon I will
live and die with the Raiders so I can
care less what the RAM has it's all
about the Raider are you and if they
want to give Jon Gruden a stake in the
team well so be it so be it if Gruden
gets
state of the raiders bring him back okay
I want Gruden as our coach all right
well looks like looks like you're you're
gonna would you go to Vegas to watch a
game there when your Raiders go Vegas
the Raiders and casinos you and Berkeley
Berkeley will be there a lot of new fans
I don't see you at like the one-armed
bandits you don't do that do when you go
to Vega you're not a gambler no I mean I
play for fun but I'm not like Sir
Charles so Charles is a hardcore gambler
yeah I have fun with I've been there
with you at the blackjack table I have I
have I've been there when he's been up
like killing them and I've been there
when he's been down when he looks at me
he's like get away from me right now
have you ever tried to say Charles
step away on the table no no no that's
that man's vice his money he's earned it
you can do whatever you want with it
yeah I told him I said he would bet on
games I said why don't you just give me
your money so you at least know it's
going to me because you're gonna lose it
so at least give it to me and I can give
it to my children he's terrible night
reg will dress up the Rockets coming up
tomorrow night against the Warriors as
only he can tomorrow night at 8:00
Eastern on TNT reg good to have you back
and safe travels we'll talk to you next
week
Thank You Theodore and dammit that's a
Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the third for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]